twenty-five percent tariffs on steel no
you will have protection for the first
time in a long while yes a tariff
protects some American steel makers but
what about the millions of companies
that make things from steel parts
they're all going to be hurt did we
learn nothing when we saw the damage
done when President Bush raised tariffs
on steel and consumers are gonna be hurt
what's been allowed to go on for decades
is disgraceful
trade is always under attack during the
election the bad guy was NAFTA there has
never been a trade deal as bad as NAFTA
many Democrats agreed NAFTA cost those
jobs 850,000 jobs but he's just raw
nafta's reduction in tariffs and trade
barriers did good things for America
Millennials love avocado toast avocado
anything take the current avocado craze
authentic nutritious creamy avocados it
wouldn't have happened without NAFTA
because in winter American avocados are
scarce but in other parts of the world
avocados are in season year-round
avocados from Mexico today Mexico
provides Americans with most of our
avocados and we pay less for them than
we would have without international
trade but the imports did not drive
American producers out of business the
iPhone is the result of years of
innovation trade also makes new things
possible Apple gets the special
materials it needs for iPhones by going
to the Congo Mongolia Egypt Brazil 63
countries in all extract silver and
platinum from the main logic board
materials are shipped to smelters in 34
different countries
Apple could do more of this in the
United States but different places offer
different skills Turkey and China are
good at smelting digging through Rock is
cheaper in Mongolia and so on Apple than
chips it's refined metal do a bunch of
other countries where it's assembled
into phone an aluminum body and foam
sheet of glass still that's just a shiny
piece of metal glass and plastic without
the software and for the first time you
can actually define the light in a scene
the highest bang jobs are those held by
techies most of them in America who
designed the software and programmed the
phone this is iPhone 10 this phone is
possible and affordable only because of
global trade this is a strike at the
heart of Michigan but what about trades
downside before NAFTA went into effect
there were two hundred and eighty-five
thousand Auto Workers in Michigan today
that number is only 160,000 Trump is
right but that's mostly because robots
now allow car makers to make cars with
fewer workers the total sales of cars
and car parts are often Americans
prosper when we specialize in things we
produce most efficiently things like
high-end machinery energy intellectual
property like moving
[Music]
music medicine internet startups not
only do Americans make more money
producing those things that jobs are
better farming and factory work are much
more dangerous and physically demanding
would you rather your kids work here or
in an air-conditioned office finally
trade hasn't reduced the total number of
American jobs today a record number of
Americans are working it's time to stop
applauding when politicians say ignorant
things like this not only did I oppose
NAFTA I stood on picket lines with
workers in opposition he and those
workers just don't understand what
creates a better life for people yes
trade hurts some Americans but many more
are better off much better off because
of trade
you